our agenda very much focuses on
strengthening of the economic and
monetary union creation of optimal
conditions for stronger economic growth
and prosperity throughout the Union
promoting the fight against tax evasion
and tax avoidance we discussed the
refugee a facility for Turkey the
current situation is a huge challenge to
the EU as a whole I don't think I need
to elaborate on that more joint efforts
are needed both to support refugees in
the region of their countries and to
control the flow of refugees into the
territory of the Union we adopted the
conclusions on the annual growth survey
and the alert mechanism report for 2016
the council agrees with the Commission's
analysis and proposals the priorities
for 16 are relaunching investment
pursuing structural reforms and ensuring
fiscal responsibility on combating v80
fraud we've discussed in a broader
perspective all member states are
increasingly worried about the loss in
VA tea collection ministers broadly
shared Commission's analysis that
European economies are recovering but
this recovery is fragile and need a
policy mix that can support and unlock
gross this means boosting investment
pursuing structural reforms to modernize
our economies and continuing fiscally
responsible policies all member states
had ratified the intergovernmental
agreement on the single resolution fund
it is now fully operational a single
resolution board in cooperation with
national resolution authorities now has
all the powers to be always failing
banks on the turkey fund we sure as a
presidency sense of urgency to get the
Turkish fund up and running however
there is still some work to be done on
financing details
to combat the financing of terrorism we
call on member states to better use
existing measures such as for example
improving asset freezes and
implementation of the first
anti-money-laundering directive
coordination between financial
intelligence units and helping
information to be shared better between
member states